Alexis Moussine-Pouchkine: Hello, everyone.
We're here at Devoxx 2014, and
I'm here with Chet and-- wait,
you're not Romain.
CHET HAASE: Nick.
NICK BUTCHER: Pourquoi?
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, good, good.
CHET HAASE: Croissant?
MALE SPEAKER: And with Nick,
and you guys came out recently
of the keynote that you did and
this was about material design.
So people might
have heard of it,
but why don't you tell us how
we got to material design, what
problem is it trying to solve,
and why do developers even
need to care about this?
NICK BUTCHER: Well, let me
take a swing at this first.
CHET HAASE: Yep.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Let's take it from the top.
What is material design?
So material design is Google's
attempt at providing a design
language, I guess you could
call it, like a holistic design
thing, to solve designing
for the range of platforms
that are out there.
So everyone is trying
to access your services
from little tiny screens like
your watches, phones, tablets,
TVs, cars, and whatever
else they end up
putting some smarts into,
so we needed some way
to make those experiences
kind of consistent
so you can learn how to
use them on one screen
and use it elsewhere.
And that's material design.
MALE SPEAKER: And that's
not just Android, right?
This is trying to--
NICK BUTCHER: Absolutely.
Yeah, yeah.
So not just a variety of
form factors, but different
platforms as well.
MALE SPEAKER: So Android
and the web, basically?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: And Polymer
would be the project that
addresses that in terms
of the implementation?
CHET HAASE: Right.
So in the keynote
today we were talking
about both of those
platforms and saying
what material design
is overall, what
are the design factors
going into it and the things
that we're going
for with the design,
and then talking about the
specific implementations
on both Polymer and Android.
MALE SPEAKER: So before we get
to why developers should care
about this and what it means
to them, how did we get there?
I mean, you mentioned
it's not the first time
we talked about themes.
We were actually talking
about something similar
in previous years here.
So how does this
change, and talk to us
about maybe Holo or
maybe about Kennedy on--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: I mean, this
is a multi-year effort and--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah
this didn't just
come down from the
mountain on a tablet
saying here is material design.
This has been an ongoing
kind of evaluation, I guess.
So I guess if you kind of rewind
a couple of years, four or five
years maybe, a lot of
products in Google,
and other companies I think,
kind of evolved on their own.
So you might have a team who
are building your Android app
and a team who are
building the web app
building whatever
your iOS app [INAUDIBLE].
And they always were kind of
like existing in isolation
so we just evolved to this point
where all these experiences
were their own things,
and they kind of
weren't really coherent.
So that was, you know,
across platforms.
And the same between apps
even from one company.
So even from Google, if you
use something like YouTube
and then something
else like Gmail,
it might not look
and feel the same.
They have their own kind
of foibles and interaction
patterns and so on so
you couldn't learn on one
and then apply it to another.
So you mentioned Kennedy.
That was an initiative we
had, I think back in 2011,
where Larry Page kind of
like set a mandate saying,
hey, this is a problem.
We need to kind of make our
properties more consistent.
So we set about a
big kind of redesign,
I guess, of updating all
of our web properties
to look and feel the same.
So that's when you got the
kind of lots more white space
and big red buttons
saying Compose and so on.
That was the Kennedy
look and feel,
but that mostly applied
to the web properties.
It didn't really apply to
some of the other things.
Like at the same time, Android
was evolving its own Holo
design language
so they're kind of
like going in their
own direction.
So I think material design
is like an evolution
of that kind of Kennedy effort
to grow up and try and provide
a kind of complete
design language
for all the different platforms.
MALE SPEAKER: So is
material design done?
I mean, are we working just
on the implementation details?
NICK BUTCHER: You guys
are done now, right?
It's done-- let's say
the framework's finished?
CHET HAASE: We're done for now.
Is design ever complete?
No, I think a lot
of the fundamentals
are there in terms of
the design aspects,
like what the consistent
approach that they have
to these things are,
the fundamentals of we
have the ideas of
paper and ink and how
things interact with the user.
And then the implementation,
sort of the V1 implementation
of that and the
Lollipop, envisioning
a lot of the
fundamentals, the plumbing
layer of actually
making this stuff work.
I think we can continue
to iterate over it,
but those I would see is being
refinements on top of material
design as opposed to
implementing other core pieces.
MALE SPEAKER: So you've
been trying very hard not
to use gibberish
from designer world.
NICK BUTCHER: Designer speak.
MALE SPEAKER: Designer speak.
Maybe you can give us an
example of what that would be?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
I think, if you look at
the spec, as we call it,
if you go to
google.com/design/spec,
there's this whole big
document detailing these rules
of material design, these
organizing principles.
And it uses quite
a lot of designer--
I think it's focused
at designers.
It says things like, "a
coherent design system,"
and uses things like,
"rational uses of space."
What was the one you
pulled me up on before?
Using?
CHET HAASE: Visual rhythm?
NICK BUTCHER: Visual
rhythm, I think, yeah.
So words like that.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
So do I need to read that?
I'm a developer.
Don't get me wrong, I want to
have engaging apps and people
to understand what
the app's supposed
to do and not look around.
I understand design
is important,
but do I really need
to go through all that?
NICK BUTCHER: We might have
different answers here.
I say yes.
CHET HAASE: I would say yes.
NICK BUTCHER: I
think you're touching
on a really important point.
I think you get a much
better product when
you have designers and
developers working close
together and you have
these tight feedback loops.
It shouldn't just be
like design happens here
and it gets thrown over the
wall and then development
tries to work out
what it actually means
and develop something.
I think you get a better product
when you work closely together,
and I think working
closely together
needs a shared vocabulary
so you're actually
talking about the same thing.
So, yes, it's
important to read it.
You can laugh at
the kind of terms
and the touchy-feely
concepts sometimes,
but getting some
of the vocabulary
to say, hey, what do
you mean by this thing?
What are you trying
to actually do here?
MALE SPEAKER: Well,
vocabulary's key.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I
think it helps in that.
And I think vice versa.
I think designers should peruse
the developer documentation
and then try and understand
the limitations of what people
are trying to build so
they know when to push
and what's just not
possible and so on.
I think it's got to
be a conversation.
MALE SPEAKER: So maybe
let's get into some
of the details for
the developers.
So do you maybe want
to talk about Android
and how some of
the main principles
actually are implemented and
things that are changing?
Is it just an evolution,
like, brand new APIs?
This is the new material design
package and the backup APIs?
How does that work?
CHET HAASE: It's not
fundamentally new stuff.
It's still standard
Android program.
What we did was add
capabilities to the platform
to handle things like
real time shadows.
API is to handle opting
into those capabilities
so if you want to actually
boost a view in [? Z ?]
to give it real time shadows, we
added APIs for you to do that.
The way that I envision what
we did in the Toolkit team
in this release was that we
looked at the design team
sort of waving their hands
and saying, material design.
We want all these sort of
general grand capabilities
and this consistent design
language, blah, blah, blah.
And then we would go in
and tease out the bits
that that meant
for the platform.
OK, when they're talking about
this, what they really mean is
they need the
rendering system to be
able to handle real time
shadows at 60 frames a second.
When they're talking
about this, what they mean
is they need the theming system
to be able to dynamically
colorize assets so that
we can brand applications.
And so then our
job in the release
was to then implement
those capabilities
and add those APIs
for a developer
to then opt into
those capabilities
in their applications.
I think that was all I
was doing with that one.
NICK BUTCHER: And I think
one of my favorite things
about it is that I
think we've enabled
a lot of backwards
compatibility behavior as well.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, exactly.
I wanted to get to that.
NICK BUTCHER: So there's some
awesome, awesome, awesome, new
work in the framework to do
things like real time shadows
and so on, but you can still
do a lot of the material
stuff on all the
platforms as well.
So I think we put
a lot of effort
into things like-- the app
compat library, in particular,
I think did a really
good job for helping
you to build material UIs.
So you can get this kind of
graceful degradation, right?
You can then only
have a single design,
because you don't want to have
to maintain two designs, two
code paths, and
just have it kind
of like do one thing on
a newer platform which
might do fancier shadows.
And it might fall back to
using a baked in background
or using something
like card view,
also in the support
library, which will give you
the real shadow implementation
on a new Lollipop device.
But then it'll give you a
reasonable approximation
on an older device.
So I really like the
way that that kind
of backless
compatibility is being
thought about when
making the new APIs.
MALE SPEAKER: So as
part of Lollipop,
a number of applications that
come with the system actually
were rewritten, or upgraded,
to material design.
NICK BUTCHER: All of them?
All of them, I think.
MALE SPEAKER: Any one
you want to point out
or are these good
examples of things
that should serve as
inspiration for developers?
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
So I think one of my favorites,
it's not an app, per se,
but I think the system UI.
I think the way that
Notifications work, especially
on the Lock Screen,
I think is brilliant.
I find it really fun where
you see the notifications
on the lock screen,
and you can instantly
expand them and get them
into different states
and interact with the
action straight away.
CHET HAASE: There's a lot
of subtle things, too,
in your interaction.
As you move the
shade up and down,
you're seeing things sort of
subtly fade and move around.
If you look really
closely, you can actually
see the shadows
reacting in real time,
because as you move things
around on the screen,
they're changing their position
relative to the light source,
the virtual light source
that's casting the shadows.
But you see other subtle
things like animated icons
actually moving around as you're
moving the shade up and down.
Just a lot more rich interaction
of the user about what's
actually going on in the system.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Also, I think the new
Play Newsstand application
did some really,
really nice animations.
Chet's favorite topic.
CHET HAASE: Yeah.
Activity transition stuff.
MALE SPEAKER: Do
you want to talk
about animations in general?
CHET HAASE: I always want
to talk about animations.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, I
know you do, but just--
NICK BUTCHER: How
long do we have?
MALE SPEAKER: You have 30
seconds, that's about it.
But, no, seriously, again,
why should you have them?
And why should you not
abuse them probably?
CHET HAASE: So I
like animations,
but mostly targeted towards
a specific reason, which
is helping the user
understand what's going on.
I think there's two
main uses of that.
One is to highlight something
to the user of information
they need to be aware of.
So like a pulsating
button on the screen
when they need to be aware
that this is the default
action that's going
to take place.
The thing that you're going
to see more of in this release
is transitioning the users.
So helping them
understand a flow
through an otherwise very
complicated system of UIs,
right?
So as they go from window
to window or from activity
to activity or fragment to
fragment in their application,
you can be exposing them to
seriously complicated user
interfaces.
How can you help them
understand how they got here,
where they came
from, what they're
supposed to do about it now.
And one of those ways
is by using animations
to transition them.
Not just pop that old UI
out and pop the new one
in, but actually share
elements between the UIs
so they understand what
their shared elements are
and what happened to the
elements that no longer are
there, what happened to the new
elements that just faded in.
So that, I think, is the really
powerful use of animations.
Not just to make things
look blingy on the screen,
but to actually help the
user be more connected
to the application experience.
MALE SPEAKER: And how does that
fit into Lollipop specifically
and the APIs and--
CHET HAASE: So one
of the big new API
areas that we enabled
was Activity Transitions.
The idea in material design
of being able specifically
to do these transitions so
that-- let's take an example.
You're in a music application,
you have a list of albums,
and you want to click
on one of the albums
and then see the songs
associated with the album.
Obviously you're
probably going to have
similar artwork for the album
in both of those pages there,
in both of those
activity windows,
so as you click on
the album, maybe we
can actually share that
element between them,
and we can share
some text, as well.
Whatever the shared elements are
between those two UIs and then
fade in and out the other
elements that go away
or come into being.
The Activity Transitions API
builds on the Transitions API
that we had in
KitKat, but makes it
available for
overall activities.
So now you can say, OK, when I
watch the following activity,
here's the animation
that I want you to run
and here are the shared
elements that you're
going to automatically
animate into place for me.
MALE SPEAKER: Do you wan
to talk about the theming?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: I think I
love the idea of having
all of that being
handled by a [INAUDIBLE].
Do you want to tell us real
quick about how it works?
NICK BUTCHER: The coloring zone?
MALE SPEAKER: Yes, the coloring.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Yeah.
So for a long time
we've been talking
about how you can use
color to have a branding
and have your
identity, personality,
in the application,
but it was kind
of a pain in the
ass to implement.
You kind of had to go to
these websites and input
this in My Colors and
download a couple of hundred
assets and XML files and dump
them into your app and so on.
And if you wanted
a couple of colors
and different looks
of the screen,
you'd have to repeat that.
So it was kind of a lot
of work for developers.
So, yeah, the framework team
has done a huge amount of work
to basically take grayscale
assets in the system,
bake them into the system, and
then at run time tint them.
So you just provide the
coloring information
as simple attributes
in your theme,
and we'll take care of doing
all the coloring for you,
which is really, really cool.
CHET HAASE: And
then, similarly, you
can also tint
things at run time.
So you can bake
them into your theme
and say, here's what I want
my overall theme to look like.
Here's the colors
that you should
use for my overall application.
But let's say you go
into some subactivity
in your application,
and you want
this screen to be
colorized according
to the information
that's in that bitmap,
then you'd go to something
like the Palette Library that's
now in Support
Library in Lollipop,
and you'd extract
information from bitmap
to get certain dominate
colors, and then
you can dynamically tint
the assets along the way.
So not in your theme,
because this is at runtime,
but dynamically
actually call Set Tint
and say, use this color for
the current background color.
NICK BUTCHER: A
good example of that
is I think the Contacts app on
Lollipop where I think we just
launched the new SMS messaging
app for other devices as well,
and that's kind of
like a utility app.
It doesn't really
have a strong brand,
so it kind of gets
itself out of the way
and just picks a color
from the contact.
So your contact, their photo, it
will pick out a distinct color,
and it will colorize
all the icons and so on.
So you get this kind of like
immersive kind of rich feel.
Like each contact
feels different.
By glancing at it, you
get a different kind
of feeling, which is
really, really a rich UI.
I like it.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
So as Lollipop is being
shipped to a number of devices
as we speak, what should
developers do now?
I mean, should they be
worried that their app's going
to be obsolete and it will
show real soon because there's
a big difference?
Or should they
gradually upgrade,
and then what resources
should they be looking at?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, this
is an interesting one,
because it's an
evaluation of Holo.
But it looks quite
different to Holo
so it's going to be
quite hard, I think,
to implement half
your app in material
and half your app
in an older design.
So I think it's going
to be a kind of thing
where you take your time
and sit back and work out
the major wins.
Like how do we
adopt the visuals,
and then how do we use
the idea of services
in our UI to get the
right shadows and so on.
CHET HAASE: And then
implementing more animations.
But I think there is a
sliding scale of activity
that they could do
in their activities.
In terms of, OK, so first thing
is you opt into the theme.
If you're only running on L,
you opt into the material theme,
and you get a bunch
of stuff for free.
If you're using the
Support Library,
you opt into the
app compat theme.
And, again, when
you're running on L,
then you would get all the
material theme stuff for free,
and that's going to give you
the standard widgets and colors,
and then you can build
on that from there.
You can say, well,
which of my assets
looks slightly out of
place in the new world?
What do I want to do
about those assets?
What animations can
I use so I no longer
have jump cut experiences
in the user flow?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
So I'd say now is the
right time to start
working on your material
app, because I guess
there's going to be
an expectation bar.
When users get Lollipop
on their device
and they start seeing the smooth
animations and the subtle use
of the shadows, it's going to
raise their expectation bar.
Like, this is what an app
should look and feel like.
So I say definitely developers
should get on it now.
MALE SPEAKER: And with compat
libraries and frameworks
that existed before, if
you're not targeting L,
you can still pretty
much do almost all of it.
It's probably harder,
but it's not impossible
if you really want to
get to that look at feel.
NICK BUTCHER: You can get
a lot of the way there.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
NICK BUTCHER: As for resources,
as to where they should go.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, on our
develop site, so d.android.com,
click through to the blog.
There's been a series of
posts about implementing
material assign of late.
And also under the
training section
there's a section on
implementing material design
and so on.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
So all developers should
learn, probably, about it.
Read this.
I haven't read it, I'll
be honest, but I will.
And everybody should just
probably try Lollipop as a user
and get inspired and
start building for it.
CHET HAASE: Enter
the material world.
MALE SPEAKER: Enter
the material world?
Oh, got it.
Cheers, everyone.